last week five of Megan Marquez closest
friends spoke to People magazine to
vilify the Duchess's father they told
the world she's being traumatized and
bullied and that none of the criticism
of her is justified because she's
perfect and wonderful sorry I just don't
buy that any true friend would have
spoken without Megan's explicit
permission and they were doing exactly
what Megan had begged her dad not to do
to speak about her in the media which
then reignited the rau with her dad and
spoke spawned a whole slew of
sensational news stories now George
Clooney has waited claiming Megan's
being chaste just like Diana was but who
exactly is chasing and bullying and
traumatizing her not her family who she
has had no contact with and who had been
silent for months as for the few scraps
of criticism in the media that's nothing
like what happened to Diana
Megan won't get the public adoration she
craves by playing the victim and trying
to manipulate the press coverage of her
she knows the family motto never
complained never explained she thinks
she can change that by getting her
friends to tell the world how wronged
yet how wonderful she is the palace and
the public understand where she's coming
from
I mean she's new to this world she's
receiving all of this abuse particularly
by the right-wing press and I wonder
what that is I will tell you a perfect
example
I'm impressed yes the right wing movie
well today they've been adoring her for
a week since when
radiant increase I haven't seen that the
son described as radiant and for the
male she was stunned I'm sorry you're
respectful you're wrong go no I'm not
I'll give you another
example so a couple of weeks ago the son
had a story which was about Megan
serving her guests
avocado toast yes and the story was all
of the poor people in the Amazon who are
losing their homes because of the
avocado toast that Megan is serving any
opportunity to not even that any royal I
know have you heard what happened to
Kate when she was with William have you
forgotten the way to Katie no yes I'm
sorry she got lots of stuff but what she
did what she kept her head down she kept
quiet and she just got on with it and
this this girl has allowed her friend
she has given her friends permission
because she feels she can't say anything
but this this business about let me just
say something about her father because I
think this is really important he gets
castigated and yes he was totally wrong
to do that paparazzi's done of course
and to release her letters yes very well
let's talk about the letter let's talk
about that letter that very clear sent a
private matter page okay this man is
alone she has got Kent into Palace
behind her she's got all of the
celebrity world behind it he's got
nobody megan has also said I do want to
say that I started off as a huge fan of
Megan and I still I'm very delighted I
did and I'm very delighted she is where
she is and I celebrate the fatter the
model family family as diversified in
this way I would though where I do agree
with you is I would advise that she
stopped speaking and the reason isn't of
why having other peoples be yep totally
all of them you wouldn't write her of a
voice yes right not because of the
reasons I suspect the Carroll is
suggesting and not because of the
caricature you've just provided the
reasons but yes God
the reasons are the following the royal
family are unelected and they are
relatively
ridged and they have it they have a
doctrine which is don't say much at all
yes and the Queen sticks to it very well
and that's why she's popular and I
suspect it's why Prince Charles isn't as
popular because he puts his mouth where
it's not wanted sometimes right I think
and I want the best for Megan that if
she didn't speak as much her popularity
would rise I do agree with Jimmy there
is some racially just one example and
also the whole sort of debate around and
I don't mean that you intended this but
the exotic stuff right I just think that
you know I'm just wondering whether
those words would be used for somebody
I'm not saying it's intentional and I
promised suggesting a few errs who
wondering what people have said this is
what George Clooney who's a close friend
has said quote she's a woman who was
seven months pregnant she's being
pursued and vilified and chased in the
same way that Diana was in its history
repeating itself and we've seen how that
ends I can't tell you how frustrating it
is to see that you're taking a letter
from a daughter to a father and
broadcasting it everywhere she's getting
a raw deal there it's irresponsible
that's what George Clooney says
Kensington Palace has declined to make
any comment I would say the media is not
taking the letter of somebody rightly
said the father has released Adele which
was very questionable and on the issue
of race I'm sorry June on this one I
cannot agree when any young woman comes
in whether she's a duchess or a princess
remember Sarah Ferguson she was teased
about the color of her hair she was
teased about Perry once two cops carried
a little bit too much weight at one
point she perhaps had rather a large
area she was teased or criticized
Brewster C flat Princess Anne has been
in her time criticized ruthlessly for
being off hand and swearing look I'm
afraid it makes no difference
he said is just not he clearly doesn't
know what happened if you make fun of
somebody because they're too fat then
you're kind of in danger of being
prejudiced against overweight people or
anyway now that's different saying
you're you know obesity isn't good for
your health but if you're actually
mocking somebody for their way right so
I think I think we've got a seed yes
others are criticized for other traits
but that doesn't mean Megan's not
criticized for her mixed heritage
I need oil though do we want to have a
look at her letter to her yeah and then
after I've got a clip I on it I
shouldn't actually even know the Bally's
content this was a private letter
written in her copperplate hand and in
which she writes to Daddy
you your actions have broken my heart
into a million pieces if you love me as
you tell the press you do please stop
please allow us to live our lives in
peace please stop lying
please stop creating so much pain please
stop exploiting my relationship with my
husband for some reason you continue
fabricating these stories Manufacturing
this fictitious narrative and
entrenching yourself deeper into this
web you've spun the only thing that
helps me sleep at night is the faith and
knowing that a lie can't live forever
hmm who is hurt who has had ghostwriter
poster it's terrible in the school
question instead of sending five
pictures I'm telling you that letter has
gone it's good my instincts are going
crazy
why allow friends to speak while she's
seven months pregnant and let that be
revealed because her hold on has spoken
she sent that letter in August I think
yes and this friend spoke is long and we
don't know for sure that she allowed her
face anyway can I bring in a video of
Kate Williams the Royal historian and
this is what she had to say Megan is
getting a much harder time the most
partly because her family are
collaborating with some of the media
some but most of the time the families
just don't say anything and eventually
it blows down like the Middletons but
Megan's family are collaborating they
are talking her half-sister
to a degree her father to a degree the
other relations are really talking for
money it seems and that is really very
distressing
so obviously Kensington Palace are going
to be very upset for her but they are
going to understand that these things
happen bullied and vilified I think the
price is really negative does she she
has also I think she's been afforded
more courtesies than any of the royal
wife or girlfriend in decades she has
she has been because they didn't want a
revelation of what happened to Diana
anyway being treated alone